today's draft the most controversial
calls the most controversial plays in
nfl history inspired by the thing that i
have to see multiple times
every friday when shireen's on with that
staubach jersey hanging in the
background shireen asked me the trivia
question and we'll decide who gets the
first pick
what color is blue mike no who is the
cowboys all-time
leading receiver yards and catches
all-time leading receiver yards and
catches all-time leading receiver yards
and catches
my goodness is it michael irvin
is it michael arfman uh jason
jason whitton oh trick question trick
question we're talking about receivers
and 88s and whatnot yes
that makes sense jason whitten witten's
up there high on the all-time
catches and yardage list uh for all
players regardless of position all right
you get the first pick
do you know who the td leader is for the
cowboys
jason whitney is one of that mark it's
jason it is
it is it michael irvin oh dez bro that's
brian amazing
uh considering they didn't throw to him
the last three years he was there it's
amazing all right
you get the first pick i get the first
pick on the most controversial plays
there are so many ways
you can go with this but i think you
have to go with the immaculate reception
which stands as one of the greatest
plays
in nfl history and it was only
controversial because of the rule back
then which has since changed that two
offensive players could not touch the
ball at the same time
and of course the raiders contend that
frenchy fuqua touched the ball and i
don't see how it's physically possible
that he could have touched this ball
but that's what they contend to this day
that they won that game
and of course the steelers ended up
upsetting them in the final seconds
uh as frank o'harris carried to the end
zone and
a steelers owner at that time art rooney
was actually in the elevator at the time
he had conceded that the raiders were
going to win the game so he went on down
to the sideline to console the team and
gets out of the elevator and says hey
what happened well that happened so they
were still talking about whether it was
a controversy or not at least they still
are in oakland and i guess now in las
vegas
i i never saw that aspect of it as
controversial though because it's so
obvious to me
that it didn't hit frenchie fuqua first
and what a dumb rule that was in the
first place
it was a dominant that that you can't
have an
offense an eligible receiver it's one
thing if it's an ineligible receiver
this that's still the rule you can't
have an offensive mom and reach up and
bat the ball
to an eligible receiver but an eligible
receiver can't touch the ball
before another teammate catches it it's
ridiculous
but even then the ball ricochets off the
raiders player's shoulder pad i
i i never to me the bigger controversy
is does the ball touch the ground
when when frank o'hara scoops it up
because there's no shot of that
uh and uh that is forever resolved by
the fact that they have a statue of
franco harris making that catch
at the pittsburgh international airport
and the ball isn't touching the ground
so there's the proof the ball did not
touch the ground
when he made that catch but that is one
of the all-time great plays but to me
the stakes weren't as high because the
steelers didn't go on to win the super
bowl that year it would be two more
years
i go with the same team on the wrong
side of the bad call on the wrong side
of the controversial call
20 years after the fact 2001 division
around playoffs the snow globe game the
epic
final game ever played at the patriots
stadium before they moved to gillette
the tuck rule game where where charles
woodson
hits tom brady the ball comes out and it
looks like a fumble it feels like a
fumble anything anyone ever knew about
football up until that point
directed it to the outcome of a fumble
and then that's the night that we learn
about
the tuck rule where and and it was a
proper application of the rule and
until the ball is tucked back into the
the gut of the quarterback when he's in
that throwing motion if the ball comes
out it's an incomplete pass so it was a
bad rule that was applied correctly to
the chagrin of raiders fans
and they eventually changed the rule
like more than 10 years after the fact
so they can get fully clear of the
controversy you don't want to change it
right away and admit
what a dumb rule it was but it was the
proper application of a bad rule
well mike i was sitting in a sports bar
in st louis because i was covering a
rams game
the next day a playoff game and i
immediately said
that's the tuck rule that's the tuck
rule and everybody's looking at me like
what are you talking
about the tuck rule but it happened
earlier in the season and i can't tell
you now
who had happened to earlier in the
season but i had seen it earlier in the
season
enough to know that that play was going
to be overturned
yes and that was number two on my list
one of the most controversial plays
in nfl history and i'm going to go to of
course
god there's so many but i'm going to go
back to 2014
did dez catch it or not and that rule
again is another one that was
changed and now we say yes if it was
applied to this year
that was a catch that des made at the
one yard line
late in that game it was a fourth down
play with a little over four minutes to
play
now i have argued with cowboys officials
over the years
that the cowboys still would not have
won that game even if they had scored a
touchdown from the one-yard line because
there was too much time for aaron
rodgers
he would have gone back down which he
did he ran
out the clock but they would have gone
back down and scored and won that game
maybe they would have maybe they
wouldn't have
that's what i argued that this packer
still would have won that game
but applied to today's rules dad's
caught that ball
and i think it was a huge controversy at
least it was a huge controversy here and
remains a controversy today
shireen based on the rules that were
enforced at the time i think he caught
that ball
one of the things i've always argued is
there was not
sufficient video evidence to overturn
the ruling on the field
and the ruling was made you saw the
official right there looking
right at it you have to have
indisputable visual evidence they've
changed the clear and obvious since then
that the the ruling on the field was
incorrect you do not have the evidence
to overturn the judgment exercise by the
official in that moment that he made the
catch that was my argument then
and it's still my argument old rules new
rules any rules
that's a catch that should have stood
regardless of what aaron rodgers would
have done with his opportunity
and it was an excellent throw by tony
romo not as good of a throw
though as the one roger staubach made to
drew pearson before he pushed
right down all right the next one for me
and i'm surprised it's still on the
board after three picks
the the play that changed the rules
to a point where they didn't know how to
enforce the rules and now we're back to
where we were two years ago the saints
rams nfc championship game debacle the
missed pass interference call
the reaction to that deafening the nfl's
effort to try to
address that situation last year
completely and totally inadequate and
now
we are exactly where we were that
doughnut hole exists again
it can still happen that you can have
the officials miss a blatant
incident of past interference and there
is no way to fix it
within the rules now you could have
al river on open up the pipeline like he
should have done
at the time and even though the rules
don't allow
the head of officiating to say to the
referee i think you should drop a flag
i am very machiavelli when it comes to
getting it right i don't care what the
process is
just get it right and i'd like to think
if they're ever encountered with
something like that again
without a rule in place to fix it they
use that pipeline
from 345 park avenue to the game site
and say
drop the flag and call it interference
to avoid that
from happening again and i think their
attitude is something like that's only
going to happen once every 100 years
it'll be somebody else's problem by the
time it ever happens again
yeah and all the plays we're talking
about mike are in the playoffs which is
why they're so significant and and you
know you have the fail mary and you have
the vinnie tessa verdi helmet ball
crossing the goal line there on the
fourth day you have a lot of those plays
but
the plays we were talking about are so
significant because they eliminated one
team
and allowed the other team in many cases
to go on and win a championship
and and it didn't happen for the rams to
win the championship but i think the
saints still feel like if they could
have gotten to the super bowl they had a
chance to win the super bowl so yes that
was very high on my list i actually had
it at number two
and shifted gears and did the des did he
catch it or not since we were kind of on
the cowboys track but
my my third choice is going to be the
1979 playoff game between
houston and pittsburgh and mike become
something of a friend of mine
and he still says he catches caught it
against pittsburgh
it looked like he caught a touchdown of
course there was no replay back then
the officials didn't signal one way or
another whether he made a touchdown or
not they consulted and said
it was an incomplete pass that he didn't
get both feet down it's very
obvious that he got both feet down it
would have tied the steelers in the
second half
cedars went on to win that game and of
course won a super bowl
in the championship game but i think the
oilers would have had a good chance to
win a championship if they could have
gotten that catch
maybe they lose that game but we'll
never know but mike renfro definitely
got both feet down
yeah that was the second straight afc
championship game between the oilers and
the steelers back when that was one of
the great rivalries
in all of football and the steelers if i
recall correctly easily beat them on
like a snowy slushy icy day
the year before right but it was that
next year where
the oilers got screwed and there were
multiple bad calls or at least
questionable calls in that game
all right last one for me and there's
still a lot i can go with and i can't
believe
i can't believe i you know what i've
i've exhausted my lifetime limit of
talking about the hail mary play and
because there's nothing that i'm ever
going to say that's going to change it
so i'm going to go i'm going to go with
the music city miracle
uh that's one that's still you know you
still see that
highlight of frank wycheck throwing the
ball across the field to kevin dyson
and it still looks like a forward pass
even though everyone insists it wasn't
and that that's why it was such a
stunning moment i remember it's one of
those
very rare nfl i know exactly where i was
when that happened because it was
unbelievable that the then titans found
a way to pull a rabbit out of the hat
and beat the bills in advance in the
postseason but it's still when you look
at it it still looks like a forward pass
not a lateral
shireen yeah and another playoff one i
think we have to mention mike is the
bird of manual catch which
change led to change rules that the
buccaneers likely would have beaten the
rams in that championship game
uh if that play had been correctly
called that was applied to the rules
then but i'm glad the rule has changed
on what a catch is
it only took him 20 years to get that
rule right though inspired by the berta
manual play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports